Ich bin Dennis, 32, und arbeite seit
zweieinhalb Jahren in der Pflege.
Ich stehe kurz vor dem Ausstieg.
Es ist zu viel Druck.
Es ist zu wenig Zeit für alles.
Es sind zu viele Überstunden.
Es sind die Schichten.
Ich kann gar nicht beschreiben,
wie viel Stress es ist.
Ich brauche abends 2 Std.,
um runterzufahren.
Das steht man auf Dauer nicht durch.
Bis 65 oder 64 ...
Nein, keine Chance.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Drängende, helle Glockenmusik *
Auf der Notfallstation
des Zürcher Kinderspitals.
Eigentlich arbeiten pro Schicht fünf
Pflegefachleute und eine Lernende,
aber der Alltag
sieht meist anders aus.
Eine ist in Quarantäne,
eine ist krank.
Also, jemand ist ausgefallen,
aber eigentlich
wären wir eine Person mehr.
Jetzt sind wir eine Person weniger.
Mal schauen.
Es geht immer irgendwie.
Nein, wirklich.
- Es geht immer?
Meistens.
Bis jetzt hat's immer geklappt.
Die Frage ist nur, wie.
Es ist weder für uns
noch für die Patienten angenehm.
Aber, ich meine ...
Noch ist es ruhig.
Die Spätschicht hat erst begonnen.
Hallo, hier ist Luca vom Notfall.
Ich habe ein Röntgen angemeldet.
Das ist Annik.
Knapp 9 Std. dauert eine Schicht,
mit kurzen Pausen dazwischen.
Noch bleibt genügend Zeit für die
Kollegin, die in der Ausbildung ist.
Hier kannst du schauen.
Da klemmt es nicht richtig ab.
Meinst du die Finger?
- Ja.
Wir machen einen besseren Verband.
Sie läuft zusätzlich auf der Schicht
und zählt einfach nicht.
Aber wir sind natürlich
trotzdem froh,
dass wir zwei Hände mehr haben.
* Quengeln *
Schau, dort ist Mami.
Du darfst wieder zu Mami.
Du willst nicht mehr, was?
Seit Mittwoch bis heute
arbeite ich in der Spätschicht,
d.h., ich arbeite jeden Tag
von 14.15 bis 23 Uhr.
Morgen und übermorgen
habe ich Nachtwache,
also von 22.30 bis 7.15 Uhr.
Dann werde ich sieben Dienste
am Stück gearbeitet haben.
(Frau) Sie hatte
einen leeren Blick ins Nichts.
Auf einer Kindernotfallstation zu
arbeiten ist wie Hochleistungssport -
extrem anspruchsvoll
bei höchster Konzentration.
* Langsame, eindringliche Musik *
Umso wichtiger, dass sich Ruhe-
und Arbeitszeiten die Waage halten.
Doch im Alltag
einer Kindernotfallstation
ist das häufig gar nicht machbar.
Es ist nicht nur,
wie du geplant wirst,
sondern du musst immer einspringen
oder bekommst ein SMS:
"Jemand ist ausgefallen.
Kann jemand einspringen?"
Wenn du dann zu Hause bist, hast du
fast ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn du dich nicht meldest.
- Ja, wir haben so einen Chat.
Z.B. kam heute um 12 Uhr
eine Nachricht:
"Wer könnte heute
noch Spätdienst machen?"
Und dann denkst du:
"Mist, ich arbeite schon."
"Wahrscheinlich sind wir einfach zu
wenige, weil sich niemand meldet."
Und wenn du nicht arbeitest,
denkst du:
"Soll ich anrufen oder nicht?"
Ich arbeite 40 %,
ich könnte ab und zu noch kommen,
aber es gibt ja einen Grund,
warum man 40 oder 60 % arbeitet.
Und dann ist man jeden Monat
zwei- oder dreimal zusätzlich da
und kann es nie kompensieren.
Das staut sich auf.
Und dann eben
das schlechte Gewissen:
"Ich muss fast gehen,
die Armen stecken in der Klemme."
Noch schöner ist es im Frühdienst.
Da ist man zu zweit oder zu dritt.
Man steht um 5 Uhr auf
und sieht im Chat:
"Kann jemand zum Frühdienst kommen?"
Das Erbrechen
beginnt ja meist in der Nacht.
Da man nicht selbst krank ist,
weiss man, dass man allein da ist.
Es geht immer irgendwie,
aber es ist so ...
Im Chat kommt einfach täglich
ein SMS für mehrere Schichten,
ob man einspringen könne.
Die Pflegefachleute sind auf
der Kindernotfallstation die Ersten,
die das kranke Kind sehen
und reagieren müssen.
Die Verantwortung ist gross.
(Flüsternd) Hoi. Okay.
(Normal) Er muss sicher
noch einmal inhalieren.
Sein Atem klingt nach Bronchitis.
- Ja.
Trinkt und isst er?
Ja, etwas weniger,
aber er trinkt und isst.- Okay.
Gehen wir in dieses Zimmer.
Die Pflegefachkräfte
machen die Erstbetreuung,
bis die Ärztin oder der Arzt kommt.
Dann dürfen Sie den Kleinen
gerne mal rausholen.
Schauen wir ihn uns mal
von Kopf bis Fuss an.
Drei Jahre Grundausbildung und
ein Zusatzstudium in Notfallpflege
sind Voraussetzung,
um hier arbeiten zu können.
* Das Kind atmet flach und röchelt. *
Der Notfall füllt sich.
Die Betten sind alle belegt.
Die Pflegefachleute
betreuen mehrere Kinder gleichzeitig.
* Leise, springende Musik *
Ich muss ein Antibiotikum richten
und mich dafür kurz konzentrieren.
Mara, ich gebe deinem Kind
in der Eins noch Teta.
Wer ist in der Eins?
Ich habe den Überblick nicht.
Der vom Baum.
- Den habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ich betreue meine Seite
und arbeite die Verordnungen ab.
Es sind viele
gleichzeitig reingekommen.
Ich muss Antibiotika anrichten,
und da ist einer nicht so fit.
Und ich habe momentan
die Schichtleitung,
weil die Schichtleitung
Essenspause macht.
D.h., ich bin
für das Telefon verantwortlich.
Und wenn wieder ein schlechtes Kind
reinkommen würde,
würde ich angepiept
und brauchte ein Zimmer.
Genau.
Sie müssen sehr viel denken,
verantworten, handeln, tun.
(Lachend) Ja.
Gut qualifizierte Pflegefachkäfte
zu finden, ist schwierig,
auch fürs Kinderspital.
* Stimmengewirr *
Offene Stellen können meist
lange nicht besetzt werden.
Einerseits findet man
nicht so viele Leute.
Auf dem Notfall ist das
ein etwas geringeres Problem,
es gibt immer wieder Bewerbungen,
aber in anderen Abteilungen
sind z.T. Stellen ausgeschrieben,
und niemand meldet sich.
Auch bei uns
melden sich nicht genug Leute.
Wir stellen alles ein,
was sich meldet,
aber es meldet sich fast niemand.
Max ist jetzt neu. Einer.
* Alle lachen. *
Im Schnitt kommen täglich
120 Kinder auf die Notfallstation,
das sind 45'000 im Jahr.
Hey, Juli.
- Sechs.
Bei Klein Julius
ist mittlerweile klar:
Er hat eine schwere akute Bronchitis.
Fertig, fertig, fertig, fertig.
Wenn etwas ist ...
... einfach den roten Knopf drücken.
- Genau.
* Schneller Alarmton *
Gerade kommt megaviel auf einmal.
Es gibt durchaus Situationen,
in denen es auch mir zu viel wird.
Wenn man nicht mal
zum Trinken und Essen kommt.
Wenn du 4 Std.
eins zu eins bei einem Kind warst,
bist du völlig am Anschlag.
Kann es gefährlich werden,
wenn's zu viel wird?
Das ist durchaus so.
Ich glaube, man kann schon sagen,
dass man gut aufpassen muss,
dass es nicht gefährlich wird.
Wir müssen solche Situationen mit
dem ganzen Team anschauen können,
damit wir sie abfangen
und bewältigen können,
bevor sie wirklich
zu gefährlich werden.
Die Arbeitsbelastung
wird immer grösser
bei praktisch gleichem
Personalbestand.
Das kann langfristig nicht aufgehen.
Wenn genügend Leute
in einer Schicht sind,
können wir
auch sehr umfassend pflegen.
Andererseits gibt es Momente,
in denen wir gefährlich pflegen.
Es geht nur noch darum,
ob das Kind atmet oder nicht.
Wir können uns nicht mehr
um die Eltern kümmern,
wir können gerade noch
das Kind überwachen.
Das ist unbefriedigend.
Damit haben wir im Moment Mühe.
Wir pflegen gefährlich.
Wenn man nach einer Schicht denkt:
"Gott sei Dank,
dass heute nichts passiert ist",
ist die Arbeit nicht mehr so schön.
Hat man dann Angst?
- Ja, und man ist unzufrieden.
Es ist nicht mehr der Beruf, den man
gelernt hat und gerne ausübt.
Wenn ich dir diese Maske aufsetze,
atmest du einfach normal weiter, ja?
Mhm.
- Wenn du stark einatmest,
bis dein Bauchnabel zum Rücken geht,
macht es dieses Geräusch.
* Schräges Pfeifen *
Gut?
- Mhm.
Mehr passiert nicht,
und du riechst Vanilleglacé.
Siehst du den Fernseher noch?
- Nein.
Warte kurz.
Und jetzt?
- Nein.
Oh, dann müssen wir
das Bett verstellen.
Die Pflege sei sein Traumberuf,
sagt Gianluca De Liquori.
Das sagen viele,
und trotzdem steigen viele aus.
Die nächsten zwei bis drei Tage
sollte die Wunde trocken bleiben.
In zehn Jahren, schätzen Experten,
werden in der Schweiz 65'000
diplomierte Pflegefachkräfte fehlen.
Wie lange bleiben Sie noch im Job?
(Lachend) Keine Ahnung.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Fragen Sie mich in fünf Jahren,
ob ich noch im Beruf bin.
Wir können uns ja alle fünf Jahre
treffen und uns das anschauen.
Keine Ahnung.
- Und die anderen hier?
Das ist schwierig.
Das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage.
Ist einfach nicht sicher,
dass alle bis 65 bleiben?
Das sicher nicht.
- Definitiv nicht.
Ich habe im Akutspital gearbeitet
und konnte nach der Arbeit
mehrere Tage lang nicht abschalten.
Ich ging nach Hause, und es
verfolgte mich bis in den Schlaf.
Ich hatte Angst, Fehler zu machen -
und ich machte auch Fehler,
weil ich so unter Zeitdruck stand.
Man kann sich das
gar nicht vorstellen,
wenn man noch nie
in einer Situation war,
dass man sich
in fünf Personen aufspalten müsste,
Weil einfach ein Diplomierter
dastehen und
Entscheidungen treffen muss und ...
Es heisst immer nur:
"Ja, das geht schon,
wir haben ja genug."
Gerade, wenn sie sagen,
sie hätten soundsoviele Betten,
denkt man: "Betten haben wir genug,
aber das Personal fehlt."
Ich habe einfach gemerkt,
dass ich das nicht länger
als einige Jahre durchhalten kann.
Ich finde das sehr schade,
denn ich habe die Arbeit dort
wirklich sehr gerne gemacht.
Meiringen im Berner Oberland, das
Alterszentrum der Stiftung Alpbach -
idyllisch gelegen,
aber abseits der Zentren.
Hier ist der Pflegenotstand
schon längst angekommen.
Der Geschäftsführer
verzweifelt manchmal fast.
Wenn ich auf JobScout
"Pflegefachfrau" eingebe,
habe ich 7'600 offene Stellen.
7'600 offene Stellen.
Und das sind inserierte Stellen.
Jemand hat dafür bezahlt.
Es gibt Betriebe, die nicht mehr
auf JobScout inserieren.
Da denke ich schon:
"Was will ich da?"
"Welche Hoffnungen kann ich mir
machen, jemanden hierherzubringen,
wenn es
so viele offene Stellen gibt?"
Das Problem ist klar:
Wir bilden 40 % zu wenig
pro Jahr aus. 40 %!
Da laufen wir einfach
gegen eine Wand.
Die Stiftung Alpbach
ist ein Pflege- und Altersheim.
Mit einem Neubau hat man hier einen
zusätzlichen Schwerpunkt gesetzt -
drei Stockwerke allein
für den Bereich Alterspsychiatrie.
* Langsame, friedvolle Musik *
Demente Menschen
finden hier ein Zuhause.
Es ist sicher kein Tag
wie der andere.
Achtung, Achtung.
Wir müssen uns
immer sehr daran anpassen,
wie es den Bewohnern geht.
Rutschen Sie noch ein wenig zurück?
Dann ist es auch ...
Man braucht
sehr viel Geduld und Empathie,
um mit Menschen mit Demenz
zu arbeiten.
Frau Kehrli, ich bringe das hier an.
Hat man das einfach
oder muss man das lernen?
Manche Mitarbeiter
bringen das einfach mit.
Es müssen nicht immer
diplomierte Mitarbeiter sein,
sondern es kann auch
Assistenzpersonal geben,
das das sehr gut macht.
Und dann ist es auch wichtig ...
Im Moment ist es sehr ruhig,
aber es gibt auch Momente,
in denen es sehr anspruchsvoll ist.
Menschen mit Demenz
brauchen wirklich Beschäftigung.
Wir hatten mal einen Dozenten,
der sagte:
"Beschäftige die Dementen,
sonst beschäftigen sie dich."
Und das stimmt. Sie brauchen
eine sinnvolle Aufgabe, sonst ...
... wird es sehr schwierig.
Ist er noch dran?
Darf ich mal schauen?
Ja, ja.
- Ah, schauen Sie, es ist fertig.
Ah, dann ist ja gut.
War's gut?
- Ja, ich bin zufrieden.
Super.
Schau, du kannst gleich
mit Irina mitgehen.
Sie hilft dir. Wir haben dich
ja nicht fertig angezogen.
Das ist gut. Da bin ich froh.
- Und wir rasieren auch gleich.
* Friedvolle Musik *
Die Betreuung dementer Menschen
hat in unserem Gesundheitssystem
einen geringen Wert.
Pflegerische Leistungen werden
vom Staat und den Krankenkassen
über das sog. BESA-System finanziert.
Du kannst gleich
ins Badezimmer kommen.
Aha. Da ist ja schon ein Stuhl.
Das ist gut.
Betreuung in Form von Gesprächen,
Zuwendung oder Beschäftigung
ist im BESA-System kaum vorgesehen.
Was demente Menschen also am meisten
brauchen, wird nicht vergütet.
* Friedvolle Klaviermelodie *
Jöggi, darf ich etwas leiser drehen?
- Ja, sicher.
Ist kein Problem?
- Das ist ganz klar.
Wir können ja einfach schauen.
- Ja, ja.
Rein vom BESA her
hätten wir täglich 5 Min.,
um mal mit den Leuten zu reden.
Wenn man darüber nachdenkt,
ist das ja nichts.
Wenn diese Arbeit
nicht bezahlt wird,
ist sie auch nicht so viel wert.
- Das stimmt.
Wir brauchen politische Vorstösse,
und die Krankenkassen müssen helfen,
es zu bezahlen.
Aber das will natürlich
niemand bezahlen.
Das ist leider unser Problem, ja.
Eine Arbeit,
die nicht angemessen bezahlt wird
und bei der für die Betreuung
der Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
nie genug Zeit bleibt,
führt langfristig zu einem Dilemma.
So, machen wir schnell Rapport?
Es erstaunt daher nicht,
wenn viele Pflegende
müde werden und resignieren.
Es ist effektiv Realität:
Diese Leute haben keine Zeit.
Das ist frustrierend.
Wenn man abends nach Hause geht,
will man das Gefühl haben,
man habe einen guten Job gemacht.
Aber Frau Müller
und Frau Meier fragen noch,
ob man noch kurz bleiben könne -
aber man kann nicht,
man hat keine Zeit.
Das ist frustrierend.
Dieser Anspruch ... Vielleicht
formulieren sie es nicht mal,
aber man weiss genau,
es wäre nötig - aber man kann nicht.
Das ist frustrierend
und bewegt viele auch
zum Ausstieg aus der Pflege.
Weil sie dem, was sie ursprünglich
für diesen Beruf gelernt haben,
nicht mehr gerecht werden.
Man ist mit der Arbeit fertig und
fühlt sich völlig unbefriedigt,
weil man weiss,
dass man mehr hätte tun können.
Was man getan hat, war einfach nur,
um das Schlimmste zu verhindern.
Eine optimale Pflege
war es aber definitiv nicht.
Eine 100-%-Stelle ist nicht 100 %,
weil man
deutlich mehr Stunden macht.
In der Regel
macht man täglich Überstunden.
In der Pflege kann man nicht einfach
die Sachen liegen lassen,
um sie am nächsten Tag zu erledigen.
Die Leute brauchen
diese Sachen jetzt, nicht in 24 Std.
Also muss man
seine Arbeit abschliessen.
Und wenn man sieht, was die nächste
Schicht alles erledigen sollte,
versucht man zumindest ...
... den eigenen Dienst
sauber zu beenden.
Da bleibt man halt so lange,
bis alles erledigt ist.
Überstunden waren bei uns normal.
Wir hatten einen regulären Betrieb
von Montag bis Freitag
mit Bereitschaftsdienst
am Wochenende.
Man hatte einen Wochenenddienst,
bei dem man während 24 Std.
Pikett hatte.
In seltenen Fällen hat man dabei
halt 22 Std. durchgearbeitet.
Wie geht das,
22 Std. am Stück arbeiten?
Man macht's.
Das ist ...
Man gewöhnt sich dran.
Ich glaube,
es könnte noch viel mehr passieren.
Das sehe ich auch tagtäglich.
Wir reissen uns den Arsch auf,
damit nichts passiert.
Darum ist vielleicht auch
noch niemand auf die Idee gekommen,
dass man das auch
anders machen könnte - es geht ja.
Walter, entschuldige.
Ich bin Lilith
und für dich zuständig.
Ich bin diplomierte Pflegefachfrau.
Du bist auf
der medizinischen Intensivstation
des Kantonsspitals St. Gallen.
Schon seit sechs Tagen.
Patient Walter ist 71,
ein COVID-Patient.
Es pfeift die ganze Zeit.
- Ja.
Daran muss man sich gewöhnen.
Das ist so.
Entschuldige, Walter.
Auf Wunsch der Angehörigen
wird Patient Walter geduzt.
Die Pflege von COVID-Patienten
ist aufwendig.
Allein eine Umlagerung
erfordert mehrere Fachpersonen.
Walter, man hört, dass deine Lunge
nicht gut belüftet ist.
Seit sechs Tagen
liegt er im künstlichen Koma.
Ihn zu pflegen und nicht zu wissen,
ob er überlebt, gehört zum Beruf.
Damit muss man umgehen können.
* Dreiton-Piepsignal *
* Gelegentliches Piepen *
Kriegt er das mit?
Das ist unklar.
Wir glauben es nicht.
Er befindet sich
in einer sehr tiefen Narkose
und hat zusätzlich eine Relaxation,
die die Muskeln relaxiert.
Dafür muss er
wirklich tief schlafen.
Darum wohl eher nicht.
Wir gehen aber immer davon aus,
dass der Patient das mitbekommt.
Darum informieren wir ihn
immer darüber, was wir tun.
Wir behandeln ihn so,
als wäre er wach.
* Punktuelle, tiefe Töne *
Lilith Bleiker ist ständig am Bett.
Sie überwacht, kontrolliert, pflegt
und handelt, wenn etwas schiefläuft.
Bis jetzt habe ich nicht abgesaugt.
Es gibt nur wenig abzusaugen,
und es ist sehr zäh -
dieses typische
gelbliche, zähe Sekret.
(Frau) Auf einer Intensivstation
wird die Pflege schon wertgeschätzt.
Und gesellschaftlich?
Ich glaube, gesellschaftlich sieht
man nicht, was die Pflege macht.
Gerade in der aktuellen Situation
mit dem Coronavirus,
ist es oft so ...
Was ich in Gesprächen mit
nichtmedizinischen Personen höre,
ist oft:
"Es gibt ja genug Beatmungsgeräte."
"Es geht ja auf."
Aber dass jemand
das Beatmungsgerät bedienen muss
und dass vielleicht
noch weitere Geräte da sind,
die man auch bedienen muss,
und dass man die nicht nur
einschalten kann und dann läuft das,
das ist der Gesellschaft
ganz sicher nicht bewusst.
Auf keinen Fall.
Lilith Bleiker ist Pflegefachfrau mit
einem Zusatzstudium in Intensivpflege
und diversen Weiterbildungen.
Eine gut ausgebildete Fachfrau,
wie es sie in der Schweiz
viel zu wenige gibt.
Auch Intensivstationen haben,
unabhängig von Corona,
zunehmend Mühe, Fachkräfte zu finden.
Einen Arbeitsplan zu machen,
sagt die Pflegedienstleiterin,
sei wie Sudoku für Fortgeschrittene.
Zu wenig Personal, und fast täglich
fallen Mitarbeitende aus.
Doch ...
Dann wünsche ich dir gute Besserung.
Wir hören am Freitag
noch einmal voneinander.
Krankheitsausfälle
kann sie kompensieren,
aber wenn jemand kündigt, lässt sich
die Stelle nicht leicht neu besetzen.
Ich danke dir. Gute Besserung
und wir hören uns am Freitag.
Gut. Danke sehr.
Tschüss, tschau, Salome.
Wenn bei uns jemand geht, brauchen
wir etwa zweieinhalb Jahre,
bis wir jemanden haben,
der gleich weit ist.
Gibt es denn auf dem Markt keine,
die so gut
und schon einsatzbereit wären?
Wir haben ausgeschrieben -
immer wieder neu,
immer wieder an einem anderen Ort.
Immer ein neues Inserat,
z.T. mit Film, z.T. ohne -
"Diplomierter Experte
für die Intensivpflege".
Ich glaube, es waren in 387 Tagen
insgesamt zehn Bewerbungen.
Ein 24-Std.-Betrieb wie die Intensiv-
station fordert viel vom Personal.
Sie müssen in Schichten arbeiten,
d.h., Früh-, Spät-
und Nachtdienst machen.
Wenn ich jetzt wieder
zu 100 % am Bett arbeiten müsste ...
Das könnte ich nicht mehr.
Ich bin zu ... Also, zu alt.
Doch, ich bin zu alt dafür.
100 %, volle Schichten
am Bett arbeiten -
das würde ich nicht mehr machen.
Ich würde reduzieren.
Ich glaube, das geht sehr vielen so.
Und die Frage ist, ob es korrekt
ist, in einem Beruf zu arbeiten,
bei dem ich reduzieren muss,
um es aushalten zu können?
Die Schichtarbeit
geht an die Substanz.
Häufige Krankheitsausfälle des
Pflegepersonals sind eine der Folgen.
Andere zu pflegen, birgt das Risiko,
selbst krank zu werden.
Man verändert die Infrastruktur,
man verändert das Material,
man optimiert Prozesse,
aber am Konstrukt der Pflege,
an den Arbeitsbedingungen
wird einfach nichts verändert.
Das geht für mich nicht auf.
Wir sind diejenigen,
die am Bett stehen.
Wir sind diejenigen, die den
Patienten fast am besten kennen.
Wir sind diejenigen,
die Komplikationen erkennen.
Es wird wirtschaftlich
absolut unterschätzt,
welche Verantwortung wir tragen
und was es ausmacht,
wenn man zufriedenes
und ausgeschlafenes Personal hat.
Es pfeift wieder.
- Ja, genau.
Ich muss schnell nachschauen. Ich
muss die Übernahmekontrolle machen.
Dass auch in anderen Berufen
Personalmangel herrscht ...
Das ist kein Argument.
Bei uns sterben Menschen.
Wir brauchen einfach mehr Leute.
Wir brauchen
attraktivere Bedingungen,
damit auch welche nachziehen
und den Beruf lernen wollen.
Mir geht es ans Körperliche.
Ich hatte irgendwann
starke Rückenprobleme.
Schlafstörungen gehören bei uns
eigentlich zum guten Ton.
Und irgendwann merkt man auch, dass
man fast kein Sozialleben mehr hat.
Wenn ich so weitermache,
habe ich keine Energie mehr,
den Beruf überhaupt noch auszuüben.
Dann arbeitet wieder einer weniger
in diesem Beruf.
Darum muss es auch für Pflegende
eine handelbare Situation geben,
damit man nicht das Gefühl hat,
dass man zu kurz kommt.
Wenn wir keinen wirklich schlimmen
Pflegenotstand haben wollen,
was ja eigentlich niemand will,
muss sich etwas ändern.
Ich finde auch, dass diejenigen,
die die Verantwortung tragen -
Politiker, das Gesundheitssystem,
die Gesundheitsdirektion ...
Es ist immer schwierig,
jemanden zu finden,
der dafür verantwortlich ist,
denn es sind viele Faktoren,
die dazu geführt haben.
Aber wenn die nicht ...
Vielleicht wäre es hilfreich,
wenn sie sich mal fragen würden:
"Was wäre, wenn sich meine Mutter
in diesem Bett wund liegen würde,
weil die Pflege keine Zeit hat?"
Im Neubau
der Stiftung Alpbach in Meiringen
stehen drei Stockwerke
für ältere Menschen mit Demenz oder
psychischen Problemen zur Verfügung.
Doch ein Stockweck steht leer -
Werner Walti hat schlicht
kein Personal gefunden.
Wir hatten das ganze Haus eröffnet
und mussten dann
einen Aufnahmestopp machen,
weil wir
nicht genug Fachpersonal hatten.
Wir hatten inseriert und gesucht.
Ohne Erfolg.
Die 14 Zimmer sind nicht besetzt,
und es ist keine Lösung in Sicht.
Werner Walti versucht alles.
Ein Mitarbeiter erzählt ihm,
in Italien gebe es viele
arbeitslose Pflegefachleute.
So fährt er mit seinem Team nach
Italien - nach Enna auf Sizilien.
Das war vor einem Jahr,
und da war Corona noch kein Thema.
Hey, das ist aber richtig genial.
Die Arbeitslosigkeit in Sizilien
liegt bei über 20 %.
In Italien werden viele
Pflegefachkräfte ausgebildet,
aber eine feste Anstellung
finden danach nur wenige.
Die suchen eine Möglichkeit,
ihr Leben zu gestalten.
Ich glaube, das würden wir auch tun.
Ich glaube, es ist ja nicht ...
Wenn ich in Deutschland
Leute rekrutiere,
müssen die Deutschen
in Polen Leute suchen,
und die Polen müssen
in Weissrussland Leute suchen.
Das ist dieser Dominoeffekt,
den wir hier nicht haben.
Wenn hier eine Stelle im Spital
frei wird, warten schon zehn darauf.
Der erste Bewerber erscheint nicht,
der zweite dafür zu früh.
Sie müssen entschuldigen,
wir mussten gerade
etwas improvisieren.
Wissen Sie bereits etwas
über unser Heim?
Ja, ich habe die Website besucht.
Ich gebe Ihnen
ein paar allgemeine Erklärungen.
Unser Haus ist ein Altersheim
mit ca. 80 Betten.
Und wir haben einen Neubau
mit drei Stockwerken.
Ich bin Pietro
und habe 2015 das Diplom gemacht.
Ich habe in verschiedenen
Institutionen gearbeitet,
auch in der Psychiatrie.
Meine letzte Erfahrung
ist eine Poliklinik.
Da arbeite ich immer noch,
bekomme aber keinen festen Vertrag.
Aber ich weiss nicht, wie ihr ...
Sie sind uns sympathisch
und machen einen guten Eindruck.
Wir werden Sie informieren.
Capito. Va bene.
Wenn's klappt, profitieren beide.
Pietro hat mit Meiringen
eine Perspektive
und Werner Walti bekommt quali-
fizierte Fachkräfte für sein Heim.
Grazie mille.
- Grazie mille.
Una buona giornata, un buon rientro.
Was glauben Sie,
wer uns morgen pflegt?
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiss es nicht.
Mit den Leuten, die wir jetzt haben,
und bei der Anzahl,
die wir jetzt ausbilden,
reicht es in zehn Jahren nicht mehr.
Ich wäre froh, wenn mich irgendwann
auch jemand pflegen würde.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte sagen,
dass uns die Lernenden von heute
morgen pflegen werden,
aber das ist einfach nicht,
was ich sehe oder im Alltag erlebe.
Da brauchen wir wirklich
eine langfristige Lösung.
Und zwar jetzt.
Wenn Sie Glück haben: ich.
Ich bin motiviert.
Aber ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss nicht, wer die Arbeit
in zehn Jahren noch macht.
Wenn sich nichts ändert,
bin ich es nicht.
Bett 1, Herr H.
Kantonsspital St. Gallen,
7 Uhr in der Früh.
Der Rapport des Teams
der medizinischen Intensivstation.
Bett 2, Frau A.,
Jahrgang 59, mit COVID,
ist GCS 3, RASS -5,
sediert, relaxiert,
kreislaufmässig stabil.
Die zweite Corona-Welle
ist im Anmarsch.
Bett 4, Herr S.,
Jahrgang 60, COVID-Patient,
GCS 8, RASS +2, hat Diso und
Seroquel - alles ein bisschen dabei.
Wurde in der Nacht
notfallmässig bronchoskopiert.
Heute noch Angehörigengespräch.
Der 71-jährige Patient Walter
ist immer noch auf der Station.
Sein Zustand hat sich verschlechtert.
Die Prognose ist nicht gut.
* Dreiton-Piepsignal *
Zwei Drittel der Betten
sind mit COVID-Erkrankten belegt.
Die Pflege ist aufwendig,
und die von COVID Betroffenen
werden immer jünger.
* Dreiton-Piepsignal *
Lilith Bleiker
betreut eine 51-jährige Frau.
Seit drei Wochen
ist sie im künstlichen Koma
und nun zusätzlich
an der Herz-Lungen-Maschine.
Wie? Was meinen Sie?
Es ist stabil schlecht, genau.
Ja.
Mir wurde gesagt,
mit Ihnen wurde heute
ein Angehörigengespräch vereinbart?
Mhm.
Genau. Und wann?
Okay. Also.
Danke Ihnen.
Gern,
und ich wünsche Ihnen viel Kraft.
Also, dann alles Gute.
Auf Wiederhören.
Das waren die Angehörigen?
- Ja, genau.
In der Pflege arbeiten
heisst auch Anteil nehmen, mitfühlen,
die vielen Schicksale mittragen.
Leider ist es eine junge Patientin -
eine Frau, die im Leben steht
und junge Söhne hat.
Die Situation ist so kritisch
und für die Angehörigen
eine so grosse Belastung,
dass ein Care Team
eingeschaltet wurde.
Gibt es für Sie auch ein Care Team?
- Nein.
Das gehört sicher
zu meinen Wünschen.
Ich hoffe, dass es das bald gibt
und dass
das Personalmanagement allgemein
einen
viel höheren Stellenwert erhält.
Das ist mit ein Grund dafür,
dass viele den Beruf verlassen.
Die zweite Welle hat erst begonnen,
und bereits stellt sich
die Frage nach den Ressourcen.
Das Personal
war schon vor Corona knapp.
Jetzt erst recht.
Ja, ist gut. Danke. Tschau.
* Telefon *
MIPS, Andreas.
Die Betten sind belegt,
die Patientenbetreuung ist aufwendig,
ein Ende nicht absehbar.
Auch Patient Walter
ist zunehmend instabil.
Herr B. ist deutlich schlechter.
Ja.
- Ich frage mich ...
Jetzt ist der letzte Moment, da man
noch über ECMO nachdenken müsste.
Das können wir noch
auf den Nachmittag verschieben.
Uns belastet v.a. die Manövermasse,
wenn man das so sagen will.
Die Zahl der Patienten,
die wir verlegen konnten,
um neue Patienten aufzunehmen,
ist fast null.
Die bleiben hier liegen?
- Ja.
Und das führt
zu ganz schwierigen Entscheidungen,
wenn neue Patienten ankommen.
Dann muss man entscheiden, ob man
einen Patienten noch aufnimmt,
ob man ihn
überhaupt noch behandeln kann,
oder kann der Patient nicht auf
der Intensivstation versorgt werden?
Das sind diese
schwierigen Entscheidungen.
Die Medizin kann vieles ermöglichen.
Ihr Erfolg ist jedoch
eng verknüpft mit der Frage,
ob es genügend Personal gibt.
Im Alterszentrum
der Stiftung Alpbach in Meiringen
freut sich der Geschäftsführer.
Er war vom Pflegenotstand
schon länger so sehr betroffen,
dass er vor einem Jahr
nach Italien reiste.
Dort konnte er diplomierte Pflege-
fachleute für den Betrieb gewinnen.
Wir machten in Milano, Neapel
und Enna Vorstellungsgespräche.
Wir haben am Ende fünf rekrutiert.
Viel haben es sich
trotzdem anders überlegt.
Es gab auch welche,
die wir ablehnten.
Wir waren wirklich
offen und transparent.
Wir sagten:
"Sie kommen in ein Bergdorf,
das muss Ihnen bewusst sein."
"Die Herausforderung ist gross."
Und diese fünf haben das gepackt.
Ich habe sie ...
Heute ist der 18. Januar.
Ich holte sie am 11. Januar
vor einem Jahr
mit dem Bus in Milano ab,
zusammen mit Claudia von Allmen.
Hast du geübt?
- Ja.
Schauen wir die Präpositionen an?
- Ja, das ist gut.
Luigi Terma ist einer von ihnen.
Er ist 23
und hat in Italien Pflege studiert.
Noch vor einem Jahr
konnte er kein Wort deutsch.
"Paul ist froh ...
... über ..."
Con accusativo - "... deinen Brief."
In einem Monat
hat er die nächste Deutschprüfung.
Die muss er bestehen,
denn sie ist Voraussetzung dafür,
dass er weiterhin als Pflegefachmann
in Meiringen arbeiten kann.
Verstehen Sie
die Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner?
Ja, ich verstehe die Bewohner
zu 90 %.
Nur wenn sie Dialekt sprechen,
verstehe ich sie nicht gut.
Aber ich kann alles machen.
In meiner Abteilung
mache ich die Tagesleitung,
Spätdienst, die normalen Dienste.
Ich spreche mit den Ärzten,
kann das Telefon beantworten,
mit Besuchern sprechen ...
Ich habe kein Problem.
Grüezi.
Grüezi, Frau Nägeli.
Luigi Terma arbeitet auf der
Pflegeabteilung der Stifung Alpbach.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Hatten Sie einen schönen Tag?
Ja.
- Ah, gut.
Kann ich kurz den Blutdruck messen,
Frau Nägeli?- Ja.
Voilà, so ist gut.
Perfekt, gut, gut.
Was haben Sie heute gemacht?
Ich habe mich ein wenig hingelegt
und war in der Cafeteria.
Ah, gut.
- Ich war auch draussen.
Wir machen das kurz.
Das ist automatisch.
Ich mache das schnell.
Meine Abteilung ist wunderbar.
Mein Chef ist tipptopp.
Auch die Bewohner sind alle nett.
Wir sind wie eine grosse Familie.
Ich liebe es, wenn die Menschen ...
Das ist für mich
ein wichtiger Beruf.
Sind Sie hier zu Hause?
- Ja.
Kein Heimweh?
- Nein, nein.
Ich fühle mich hier tipptopp.
Das freut mich.
- Danke.
Er macht seine Arbeit flott,
nicht, Luigi?
Wir sind froh,
wenn wir hier Betreuer haben.
Ja. Ja.
Alter hat Respekt verdient.
Dieser Respekt ist mir so wichtig.
Ich merke einfach,
dass er stark verloren gegangen ist.
Es leistet nicht mehr,
es sitzt nur noch da,
es produziert nichts -
hat das dann eigentlich
noch einen Sinn?
Sie haben den Eindruck, wenn man
das Alter mehr würdigen würde,
wäre es auch attraktiver,
mit alten Menschen zu arbeiten?
Es erhält einen grösseren Wert.
Auch das erhält mehr Wert.
Wenn ich mit alten Leuten arbeite
und weiss,
dass sie wertgeschätzt werden,
arbeite ich
mit einem Wertgeschätzten.
Im Pflegeheim
sind die Stellen besetzt,
dafür gibt es hier eine Vakanz.
Guten Appetit. Bis nachher.
Die Teamleiterin der Demenzstation
hat gekündigt.
Wir machen hier körperlich
wie psychisch einen harten Job.
Ich werde nicht jünger, muss aber
noch einige Jahre arbeiten.
Ich habe
eine neue Herausforderung gefunden,
die mehr so ein Bürojob ist,
von dem ich aber denke,
dass ich ihn
bis zum Ende machen kann.
Ich fühle mich zwar noch fit,
weiss aber nicht,
wie lange ich das
körperlich noch mitmachen kann.
Das ist war ein wichtiger Grund
für meine Kündigung.
Wenn es heute schon schwierig ist,
qualifizierte Fachkräfte für die
Pflege von alten Menschen zu finden,
stellt sich die Frage:
Wer wird diese Arbeit
in Zukunft machen?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Können Sie mich nicht
näher schieben?
* Stimmengewirr *
Diese Leute brauchen
so viel Wärme und Berührung,
um sich bei uns wenigstens
einigermassen wohlzufühlen.
Ich weiss nicht,
wer das künftig machen wird.
Das wird sicher ein Problem werden.
Um ehrlich zu sein, hoffe ich,
dass das ganze Gesundheitssystem
zusammenbricht,
damit man endlich mal sieht,
was geleistet wird.
Was nötig ist,
damit es funktioniert.
Was es bedeutet,
wenn wir nicht mehr da sind.
Wie viele Jahre
ist Ihre Ausbildung her?
Eindreiviertel Jahre.
- Wie lange bleiben Sie noch?
Ich habe gerade
eine neue Stelle angetreten,
also hoffentlich noch eine Weile,
aber wenn sich
die Bedingungen nicht ändern,
wahrscheinlich nicht so lange.
Viele, die mit mir
abgeschlossen haben,
sind schon in einer Krise
und denken schon darüber nach,
den Beruf zu verlassen -
einige sind schon weg.
Ich war definitiv
auch schon an dem Punkt,
an dem es genug war
und ich etwas Neues wollte.
Wie lange
bleiben Sie noch in der Pflege?
So lange ich kann, aber ...
Wenn sich nichts bessert,
sicher nicht lange.
Ich glaube, der letzte Tropfen
ist ins Fass gefallen.
Jetzt stehen mehr für sich ein
und es rollt langsam an.
Ich hoffe, wir können den Ball am
Rollen halten, bis es besser wird.
Auf der Intensivstation
in St. Gallen.
Physiotherapeutinnen,
Pflegefachfrauen und -männer,
Ärztinnen und Ärzte - sie alle
sind seit Beginn der Pandemie
immer an den Betten
der Schwerkranken.
Wie ist das?
- Nicht gut.
Was ist nicht gut?
* Unverständliche Frage *
Ich habe sie.
Ich finde es sehr eindrücklich,
das jetzt so zu erleben.
Ich habe auch Angst -
um meine Mitarbeiter, um mich,
aber auch um die Gesellschaft.
Um die Grundversorgung
der Gesellschaft.
Denn nur eine ausgeruhte Pflegende
kann Leistung bringen.
So entstehen einfach
viel mehr Komplikationen -
beim Patienten, aber natürlich
auch bei den Pflegenden.
Es hat auch
gesundheitliche Auswirkungen.
Wenn in zehn Jahren mutmasslich
65'000 Pflegefachkräfte fehlen,
wird das alle treffen.
* Dreiton-Piepsignal *
* Schnelles Piepen *
Die Corona-Pandemie
ist wie ein Vorbote.
Sie zeigt:
Wenn viele Menschen Hilfe brauchen,
aber die personellen Ressourcen
knapp werden,
ist nicht mehr sicher,
ob es für alle reicht.
Irgendwann geht's nicht mehr.
Man bekommt nicht mehr Leute.
Dann werden
die Ressourcen am Bett knapp.
Dann die richtigen Entscheidungen
zu treffen,
ist mit einem
ziemlich grossen Druck verbunden.
Das ist schwierig.
Das ist für uns alle
eine besondere Herausforderung.
Salopp gefragt: Ist das das, was die
Menschen noch nicht kapiert haben?
Es geht nicht um Betten,
sondern ums Personal?
So ist es.
Ein Bett ist schnell aufgestellt,
aber das Entscheidende ist,
dass man an den vorhandenen Betten
adäquat ausgebildetes Personal hat,
das sie betreiben kann -
pflegerisches
und ärztliches Personal.
Unser Gesundheitssystem
baut auf junge Fachkräfte,
die im besten Sinn für das Wohl ihrer
Patientinnen und Patienten sorgen.
Was meinst du von der Belüftung her?
Ja.
- Ja.
Doch die Jungen sind nach wenigen
Berufsjahren oft ausgebrannt.
Bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
sind gefragt,
um sie im Beruf zu halten.
Davon würde
nicht nur das Personal profitieren,
sondern die ganze Gesellschaft.
Es ist ein unglaublich toller Beruf,
wirklich. Ich liebe ihn.
Ich finde es umso trauriger
und es macht mich ohnmächtig,
wenn ich sehe, dass ich
aufgrund der Arbeitsbedingungen
meinen Beruf nicht oder nicht mehr
so ausüben kann, wie ich will -
also hochprozentig.
Das ist sehr schade,
denn ich glaube, es gibt sehr viele,
die die Begabung hätten
und die den Beruf
einfach nicht ausüben
oder sehr früh vom Bett weggehen.
Weil es einfach zu hart ist?
- Ja.
Wenn die Ressourcen vorhanden sind,
geschehen kleine Wunder.
Eines davon ist Patient Walter,
der 71-jährige COVID-Patient.
Er hat überlebt.
Ein Tagebuch erinnert ihn
an die Zeit von damals,
geschrieben von den Pflegenden
der Intensivstation.
Hier schreibt eine Pflegerin,
Elvira:
"Erneut betreue ich dich ..."
Sie durften mich immer duzen.
Meine Tochter sagte ihnen, sie
müssten mich duzen, ich möge das.
Sie schrieb: "Hallo, Walter."
"Erneut betreue ich dich heute
im Nachtdienst."
"Im Spätdienst konnte man
die Beatmungsmaschine so umstellen,
dass du nun selbst atmest."
"Ich hoffe sehr,
dass du in den nächsten Tagen
weiterhin Fortschritte machst.
Alles Gute, Elvira."
Und so könnte ich hier
stundenlang lesen.
Ich habe es auch gelesen.
Es war sehr eindrücklich.
Es hat mich sehr berührt.
Was berührt Sie?
Was für mich alles geleistet wurde.
Unglaublich.
Das ist ein Betrieb,
der 24 Std. läuft,
und ich allein habe schon
einen solchen Maschinenpark.
Das ist ja
ein unglaublicher Aufwand -
nur wegen einem,
der nicht mehr atmen kann.
Und das war ich.
Zum Glück lag für mich alles bereit.
Walter Betschart hat Glück gehabt.
Noch waren genügend Ressourcen da
und haben dieses Happy End
möglich gemacht.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021